présidentielle l'interview sur Radio
Classique et publ
Sénat Marine Le Pen bonjour on vous
retrouve évidemment avec Guillaume nous
sommes sur l'antenne de Public Sénat et
de Radio Classique et un petit mot de
comment peut-on dire de compassion ce
matin pour jolie parce que peut-être
qu'il y a une solidarité finalement pour
les candidats en campagne bien sûr moi
j'espère qu'elle va se remettre vite
enfin je pense que les nouvelles sont
plutôt rassurantes la grande question
qui est posée ce matin sur le plan
politique c'est les chiffres de l'OC qui
pronostiqu vous l'avez vu vous l'avez lu
vous l'avez entendu une abstention
colossale 32 % en premier tour vous
l'expliquez comment je pense qu'il y a
plus d'un Français sur deux qui ne
veulent pas du duel François Hollande
Nicolas Sarkozy ils n'en veulent pas or
c'est ce duel là qu'on nous impose
depuis 3 mois ils se sont répartis 60 %
des temp d'antenne à tous les deux
depuis le le 1er janvier et il y a une
sorte de démoralisation voilà et qui est
entretenue faut bien le dire par les
sondages qui persiste donc ça veut dire
quoi ça que les sondages sont manipulés
quand ils vous mettent en recul à peu
près tous écoute en tout cas vu les
différ écoutez vu les différences qui
existent entre les sondages il y a quand
même une partie d'entre eux qui sont
soit des incompétents soit des
malhonnêtes parce que on peut pas se
tromper de de 12 à à 18 quand même je
veux dire bon donc on sait que les
sondages quand même sont très proches
hein de de des uns ou des autres que ce
soit de l'UMP ou ou ou des socialistes
les les instituts sondages donc je pense
qu'il y a une opération mais c'est
peut-être la photo de la vérité Marine
Le Pen je crois pas moi je crois qu'il y
a une opération de démoralisation quel
thème mais si que vous avez des
informations il y a une opération de
démoralisation de du peuple français on
veut le pousser à ne pas aller voter
pour laisser persister ce faux duel ce
faux duel qui est celui de l'UMP du PS
qui metne la même politique depuis 30
ans alors un coup à toi les régions à
moi l'État et puis ben toi avec moi moi
avec toi toi après moi et cetera et
cetera et il faut que les Français se
sortent de ça il faut qu'il se sorte de
ce duel imposé parce qu'il n'est pas
celui qui apportera évidemment des
solutions n guume Tabar sur ce thème
l'abstention vous parlez de du imposé
mais ce sont les mêmes sondages qui à
l'automne vous donnez en forte
progression vous ont donnez même souvent
au-dessus des 20 % est qu'il y a pas
même présente au deè tour est-il y pas
des questions aussi que vous pouvez vous
poser sur votre campagne à vous non
monsieur Mo ce que je crois c'est que
les les sondages sont des usines à
fabriquer de l'argent voilà et par
conséquent il faut que chacun fasse son
coup alors un coup on met al tout le
monde aura été au premier hein Holland
aura été premier Marine Le Pen aurait
été premier Nicolas Sarkozi aurait été
premier et puis le 3è homme alors on a
eu la séquence baayrou qui était le 3è
homme et puis après la séquence
Mélenchon le 3è homme et cetera on nous
a fait le même coup en 2002 je vous
rappelle au même moment où on se parle
en 2002 Harlet laguier est à 10 et demi
Jean-Marie Le Pen est à 10 Jean-Marie Le
Pen finit à 17 aret laguer finit à 5 et
demi voilà donc euh moi je demande aux
Français de s'attacher dans les trois
prochaines semaines à regarder les
programmes à juger aussi de la moralité
de ceux qui se présentent et a arrêté de
rentrer dans ses opération commerciales
que sont les sondages ça veut dire quoi
la moralité la moralité la moralité vous
savez la morale vous savez ce que c'est
la morale pré tout à fait mais ça veut
dire quel contenu quel personnage la
moralité c'est qu'est-ce que les gens
ont promis et qu'ont-ils fait de leurs
promesses ont-ils trahi les Français se
sont-ils correctement comportés ont-ils
270 casseroles qui tinent à leur fesses
lorsqu'ils avancent voilà ça oh je parle
d'un certain nombre de personnes qui
aujourd'hui espèrent notamment être
réélu et qui ont multiplier les
affaires qui ont multiplié les affaires
je pense à un qui espère être élu et et
dont les deux plus grosses fédérations
sont le centre de d'une corruption
mafieuse sur lequelle il ne sa jamais
sur lequel il ne s'est jamais expliqué
parce que évidemment voyez-vous je crois
quen en politique c'est important mais
je reviens à la question de Guillaume
parce que à un moment il faut aussi se
regarder en face nous pareil d'ailleurs
les journalistes mais est-ce que vous ne
considérez pas quand même que d'une
certaine manière depuis un certain temps
l'ensemble de votre programme
c'est-à-dire la baisse de la TIPP les
augmentation qui soit des augmentations
du minimum vieillesse des salaires ou la
sortie progressive de l'euro peut-être
que ce programme je dis bien peut-être
que ce programme n'imprime plus je suis
absolument pas d'accord avec ça ça ça
m'étonne pas mais
que peut-être que les gens ne le
trouvent pas crédible sont desabusés je
vous pose la question mais monsieur s'il
y a des gens qui le trouvent pas
crédible c'est parce qu'en face de moi
j'ai un système qui a tout intérêt à ce
que le modèle économique qu'ils nous ont
vendu perdure et vous savez pourquoi
parce que ce modèle économique il a
enrichi un petit nombre et il est en
train d'appauvrir l'ensemble du peuple
il y a des gens qui bénéficient de ce
modèle économique les gros les les
grandes multinationales les banques sont
très heureuses de ce modèle économique
il faut surtout pas que Marine Le Pen
soit élu pour changer ce modèle
économique reprenne l'argent là où il a
été capté pour le rendre au peuple
français et pourtant les propositions
que je peux faire sont appliquées par
d'autres pays la baisse de la TIPP et le
financement de cette baisse par une
taxation sur les grandes entreprises
pétrolières et gazières ça a été fait en
Grande-Bretagne le protectionnisme
intelligent s fait actuellement en
Amérique en Amérique du Sud dans tous
les pays d'Amérique du Sud le
protectionnisme social qui consiste à
réserver les aides sociales aux Français
c'est fait dans toute une série de pays
bon mais évidemment c'est un système où
les banques vont y perdre les grandes
multinationales vont y perdre la grande
distribution va y perdre ces grands
groupes qui aujourd'hui ont tuer la
concurrence des indépendants et qui
multiplie les ententes entre elles entre
eux pardon pour piquer le pouvoir
d'achat des Français ils vont y perdre
et est-ce que vous ne songez pas dans
cette affaire justement peut-être au
fait que le Président de la République
notamment dans cette dernière phase dans
cette dernière séquence a reconquis une
partie de ce qui pouvait être il y a
encore quelques semaines votre électorat
je ne peux pas croire je ne peux pas
croire fr qu parle de la réévaluation de
Schengen mais je ne peux pas cro après
la fermer que les Français puissent
imaginer qu'il fera demain ce qu'il n'a
ni su ni voulu ni pu faire hier moi je
vais vous dire une chose les Français
ont 3 semaines pour comprendre
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est que la
conjonction entre l'immigration et le
chômage dans notre pays est mortel voilà
il est mortel pour notre nation or
l'immigration et le chômage ont été
voulu par le système voulu par l'UMP et
le PS toutes les mesures qui ont été
prises depuis 30 ans ont consista à
soumettre notre pays au chômage et à
l'immigration pourquoi parce que ceci
crée une concurrence qui encore une fois
bénéficie à quelques-uns affaibli les
capacités de résistance du peuple
français quand vous êtes quand vous
doutez vous êtes moins fier et donc
moins dangereux quand vous souffrez vous
êtes plus vulnérable on a mis en place
les conditions de la
vulnérabilité économique social et donc
psychologique des Français pour pouvoir
avoir un pouvoir sur eu Guillaume Tabar
question aprs tout ça n'a pas changé
d'un seul coup donc Nicolas Sarkozi a
fait quelques propositions précises pour
durcir les conditions duouement familial
pour
fixer des critères pour d'attribution de
prestation sociale pour les étrangers
ramen les entrées en France de 200000
100000 est- dans sens de ce que vous
souhaitez monsieur il a augmenté
l'immigration jusqu'à
203000 légalement par an ça veut dire
que sous son quinquena c'est entre les
légaux les illégaux et les enfants nés
sur le
territoire qui ont vocation à devenir
français c'est 2 millions d'étrangers en
plus que Nicolas
Sarkozi a fait entrer dans notre pays ça
c'est le bilan et pour ces propositions
pour le quen à venir mais il fera pareil
monsieur il fera la même chose parce
qu'encore une fois il est soumis aux
revendications du meddeef or le meddeef
a besoin de cette immigration pour créer
la concurrence avec les salariés
français et donc peser à la baisse sur
les salaires et détruire notre système
de protection sociale car vous voyez
bien que avec une immigration aussi
importante la sécurité sociale l'hôpital
l'éducation nationale le logement social
explose sous le poids de cette
immigration dans C mais madame dans ces
conditions comment vous expliquez qu'au
premier tour actuellement il y a une
remontée parce que je reviens à ce que
disait Guillaume il y a plusieurs
semaines les gens s'interrogeaient
est-ce que Madame Le Pen va être devant
Nicolas Sarkozi or maintenant on voit
que vous êtes très loin derrière plus à
plus de 10 point et que lui progresse
justement
dans vous m'avez dit
manipulation est-ce que vous imaginez
écoutez est-ce que vous imaginez
avouz-vous du nez c'est ça est c'est la
c'est la tirade du nez est-ce que vous
imaginez que Nicolas Sarkozi soit à deux
points de son résultat de 2007 à
l'époque où il y avait une dynamique
incroyable autour de sa candidature
est-ce que vous n'entendez pas les
milliers de gens qui disent plus jamais
nous nous laisserons avoir par Nicolas
Sarkozi une fois ça suffit ça fait 10
ans monsieur ça fait 10 ans qu'il est
chargé de l'imargum du vot u àoite
fctionne 10 ans qu'il est chargé de la
sécurité qui a explosé dans notre pays
vous les entendez pas ces milliers de
gens ces centaines de milliers de gens
qui disent je ne voterai plus jamais
Nicolas Sarkozy mais peut-être qu'au
contraire l'argument du vote utile qu'on
entend à gauche à l'égard de Mélenchon
peut fonctionner à droite vous
concernant quelle est l'utilité du vote
de Nicolas Sarkozi si ce n'est renforcé
un système dont une très grande parttie
part des Français ne veulent plus le
seul vote utile antiystème c'est le vote
pour une candidature qui est capable
d'accéder au second tour or la seule
candidature et tout le monde le sait
bien qui est capable d'accéder au second
tour c'est la mienne voilà tout le monde
finalement l'abstention à 32% vous
considz que c'est une même même les gens
de chez Mélenchon ne croient absolument
pas au fait que il soit passé devant
Marine Le Pen bon allez disons les
choses telles qu'elles sont alors
arrêtons de créer des leures le système
crée des leures pour tenter d' fumer les
Français et de les pousser à ne pas
aller voter pour parce que ils ne
veulent évidemment pas que le que le le
le changement arrive Guillaume Tabar
Rostan et si malgré tout à l'arrivée les
Français imposent par leur vote une
finale entre François Hollande et
Nicolas Sarkozi est-ce qu'il y en a un
des deux dont vous sentez le plus proche
notamment sur les questions dont vous
venez de parler sur l'immigration sur
sur le protectionnisme et CEA mais
monsieur
Tabar Monsieur Sarkozy et Monsieur
Hollande ont impos er aux Français
ensemble le traité de Lisbonne ce traité
de Lisbon qui ve sortir de Schengen
l'utre écoutez-moi ce traité de Lisbonne
interdit toute mesur protectionnisme
pour pour notre économie l'interdit ils
ont gravé dans le marbre l'interdiction
du Small Business Act que Nicolas
Sarkozi cherche à vendre aujourd'hui
qu'il est venu puiser d'ailleurs dans le
programme de Marine Le Pen interdit le
fait de donner un avantage à nos
entreprises interdit d'aider des
secteurs économiques en difficulté
interdit de réserver des aides sociales
aux Français ce le traité de Lisbonne
interdit tout cela or ils l'ont voté et
imposé ensemble contre la volonté des
Français pourquoi voulez-vous que je
puisse imaginer une demi-seonde que je
sais pas touché par la grâce ces deux
candidats qui ont 40 ans de vie ou 30
ans de vie politique derrière eux et
pour l'un et pour l'autre qui ont tout
été dans la République toalement se
rendrait compte que le système qu'ils
ont renforcé est nuisible à la France
donc si vous n'êtes pas au de si vous
n'êtes pas au deuxème tour on prend ça
comme hypothèse puis qu'évidemment vous
la refusez cette hypothèse mais si vous
n'y étiez pas il n'y aura pas à aucun
moment de déclaration en faveur de l'un
ou les deux autres mais est-ce que moi
je suis contre
l'euthanasie y compris y compris pour
mon
pays je ne participerai pas à donner la
mort à mon pays et à ma civilisation je
veux que mon pays vive je veux qu'il pr
je veux que l'extraordinaire
civilisation qui est la nôtre puisse
perdurer dans le temps les valeurs
auxquelles nous sommes attachés or ces
deuxlà sont les candidats de
l'Immigration et du chômage et je vous
dis que la conjonction de ces deux
éléments c'est la mort de notre pays et
la mort de notre civilisation parnez-moi
cette question franche mais est-ce qu'
vous n'auriez pas besoin plus de la
présence de votre père dans cette
campagne est-ce que vous considérez que
une partie de l'électorat du Front
national finalement vit dans la
nostalgie mais attendez vous avez vu ça
où
que où avez vu
vousvez vu cel j'ai le j'ai le la les la
certitude de vote la plus forte de cette
campagne 85 % des gens qui disent qu'ils
vont voter pour moi disent qu'ils ne
changeront pas d'avis ça n'est pas le
cas des autres candidats et bien
j'entends bien dans les 3 semaines
convaincre encore plus de personnes et
Monsieur durant je crois très
sincèrement que la les sondeurs et la
classe politique devrait être prudente
parce que si j'en crois les réactions de
terrain que je vois mais que les autres
voient aussi on peut avoir une très
grande surprise à nouveau dans cette
élection présidentielle dieu merci
d'ailleurs dieu merci que ce duel
Sarkozy et Hollande n'est pas une
fatalité et vous maintenz aujourd'hui
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon fera moitié moins
de voix que vous oui Jean-Luc Mélenchon
est un est un bout en train au sens
hypologique du terme il est là pour
ramener à l'écurie de Monsieur Hollande
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec Anne Sophie
Lapix de Canal plus à chaque fois que
vous passez dans son émission on a
l'impression qu'une certaine forme de de
détestation vous oppose ah elle me haie
parce qu'elle participe d'un système son
boulot tout simplement non non elle par
non parce que son boulot c'est pas de me
haïir ni de me combattre c'est de
m'interviewer c'est pas de m'interroger
elle est pas juge d'instruction non la
réalité c'est qu'elle est mariée avec le
patron de Publicis et que elle participe
donc disons par mariage d'un système qui
me combattra jusqu'au dernier moment
parce que je le combats pourquoi
pourquoi quce que vous avez contre
publicisme ah mais parce que j'ai j'ai
contre toutes ce tout ce système qui
mange ensemble qui a été élevé ensemble
qui met ses enfants dans les mêmes
écoles et qui a squatté le pouvoir dans
notre pays en l'arrachant au peuple
français voilà mon but c'est de prendre
ce pouvoir à ce système lui prendre et
le rendre au peuple français c'est tout
le sens de ma candidature tout le sens
du combat que je mène depuis déjà de
très nombreuses années
j'allais prononcer un mot ça c'est pas
de je l'oublie ce mot je l'oublie pour
ce matin
8h 9h30